we don't like to bet but okay it is the
king's pawn okay magnus
he's maybe wow okay napolita opening
with the sicilian
um the pogbachie that is one of his
favorite ways well it's
his by far his favorite way of meeting
the king's porn opening and now
we do see not the main line no open
sicilian yet
but a bit of uh yeah bit of bluff by
both players i think
now okay carlson developing his knight
the pontiac
also bringing his knight towards the
center this is a key moment will carlson
he does open up the center so this is
called an open sicilian
it's likely it transposes to the taimaan
of
sicilian he uh he lost to giri with the
black
pieces and he actually beat hikaru
nakamura in that tournament and
uh david is totally right always want to
jump forward and attack the black queen
um that has not been allowed everybody's
been playing over the last
four or five years was to bring out the
white queen in that position but instead
magnus just developed his bishop
getting ready to castle the white king
to the right side of the board often
they try to castle to the left if
they're feeling super ambitious but
magnus just trying to play a quieter
game um napoleon actually saying no
no quiet game for you i'm gonna push
pawns and napoli actually they're
playing the most ambitious the most
aggressive move for black
that pawn is destined to push forward
one square further if it can
to kick away one of white's knights from
the center and he doesn't want to rely
purely on that but okay he does play one
of the most common moves knight takes
knight
and the black queen immediately
recaptures
my secret's here um but okay we're we're
seeing
very well known stuff white's pawn
pushing forward
white's bishop now challenging the black
queen along the diagonal
yes sorry david this is just actually a
repetition of
gary's game against nepomniacci right
now
okay there we go the light squared
bishops disappear from the board yeah
now
will we see the white king castle no we
see the queen this is what gary played
this is exactly what gary played and uh
so this was two months ago yeah two
months ago and well now we have a change
because uh napoleon actually chose to
develop
a dark square bishop and to pin the
white knight and now he has
developed his knight yeah and because
the thing is with uh with this
you used to sew it fluctuating so wildly
that i i don't think
i think it's one of those things that i
don't know i would appeal to the
my risk loving side oh no pony actually
thinks maybe we can bring up the
analysis board just to show the main
ideas in this position
um so last move magnus did bring his
bishop into black's half of the board
he is eyeing up this diagonal and
there's a bit of an
idea here if you do just try and kick
this bishop away if you bring your rook
across try to harass this bishop
white knight is going to jump into the
center of the board and suddenly
black does have a very weak square in
his camp this is an outpost
all of white's pieces are controlling
this square and if white's knight can
jump there that's going to be
what we call a family fork the king's
going to be attacked the queen and the
rook
so black cannot allow that wow napoli
actually instead
does get greedy queen takes pawn i mean
i barely considered this i don't know
about you ivanka but he takes this pawn
it looks like an irrelevant one um but
now surely white is just gonna castle
his king to the other side
and laugh at black say what's your queen
doing there it's off in siberia
somewhere
and um suddenly there's a threat of
queen takes pawn
checkmate um white queen if it does
capture that pawn it will be protected
by the rook behind it and black's king
in huge
trouble right now the black queen is
going to have to scamper back she's
going to have to run the whole way back
but black's lost two moves
just for the sake of one pawn and it
looks like white might be
able to build up an attack by bringing
his knight into the center of the board
now
yeah well well he's actually on the
board david
i mean i i agree with you when it comes
to uh
timing and everything it looks looks
quite risky but it is a pawn
and we do here we do love the little
guys
yeah pawns are the soul of chess that's
right yeah and
okay well the action really is heating
up because uh magnus centralized his
night and that night was
also threatening all sorts of unpleasant
checks and
uh this is why napoli actually has been
forced to make
his knight move and now the big question
is
how is magnus going to justify
his pawn deficit but on the other hand
we have a situation where
black can't do anything you know black
can mobilize one rook
and then white can simply improve the
pieces okay so magnus
has centralized the one rook that wasn't
working
and so his intention now is presumably
to do what he likes he can
step it up one square and then try to
set up some kind of
triple alignment with the queen and the
rooks he could have done that last move
though so maybe
maybe not um his immediate idea i think
that's just a very magnus
carson type of move right that rook was
doing nothing so before you even
calculate before you even come up with a
plan just improve it first
and um all of white's pieces nicely
centralized now attack we have to
yeah we're gonna see this uh black did
bring his rook across and one thing i
think
white should be aiming for as you
mentioned is maybe to just to shuffle
the rook up one square
uh if black continues to do nothing then
bring the rook across and this is going
to be a very
nice kind of setup for white but first
we did well we're on form with the
predictions ivanka
we did predict that white would bring
his king across one square this is a
general rule that i think is useful for
everyone at home
if you castle over on the long side we
call it queen side castling
if you castle over to the left side of
the board with white or the same with
black you always want to take a step
over again with the king it means that
you have three pawns
sheltering the king and for example you
won't be
under attack by any diagonals later on
so it's always important to shuffle your
king over
even if there's no immediate rush or
need for it just
spend that extra move your king will
feel much safer and thank you for it
later on
in the game and now napoli actually has
the question what to do
one move i'm slightly tempted to uh
suggest for black i don't think it's
very good
but one move i would be tempted to
suggest is to just shuffle the king
across
and run away this way you think no
you're right
no no you don't need to do anything
david
better to sit still right oh okay why
this is what we were kind of i was kind
of worrying a little about what is black
going to do and the probably actually
does have an answer and he's saying that
he
wants to break he does have his
calculating face on
okay then he looks away um knowing
magnus normally when he's kind of
just staring not flinching too much he's
calculating and in the end
okay wow ivanka you're looking shocked
um i feel shocked that he didn't open up
the position
all of white's pieces are ready to ready
to start
firing and exactly because the goal when
you're
when you're attacking is to open lines
that is your currency and so for magnus
not to
automatically go pawn takes pawn open up
the rook
and i just think that the knight coming
forward is just asking to be played well
this is the beauty about chess you know
it is not computers playing the game
it's two humans and you
you can easily get caught up in the fog
of war you can overlook things you can
just uh
i think magnus is looking back and
thinking back to those previous
opportunities
um yeah black looking pretty solid the
black king obviously still not ideally
placed
if you could kind of pick up the black
king and put it in one of the two
corners not sure which one
then black would feel very very happy
but meanwhile magnus
uh just bringing the white rook across
no you guys though because you didn't
see it but if people at home
we've seen a huge blunder on the morning
by the pontiac uh napoli actually trying
to trade the queens trying to head to an
end game but
he's just missed this last move white
jumping in with his knight giving check
and if that night is taken then there
are consequences white's queen will jump
into the position as she blacks about to
lose
either a rook or a queen no uh napoli
actually we see it on his face
um he did not even consider that move
that's why we always say
look for checks first in every position
because if they work they're extremely
strong
they're extremely powerful and the pony
actually just a one-move blunder in a
solid position
he should have slow played it he rushed
maybe feeding the tension feeling the
pressure and the
momentous occasion um he wanted to
eliminate that by trading queens and now
he's dead lost and the mistake was
bringing his queen into the middle of
the board and
magnus immediately punishing it knight
jumping into the position attacking the
king
and attacking the rook if this knight
gets captured i mean if it doesn't you
can just take the rook
if it gets captured though then suddenly
white's queen would jump into the
position giving check
and when the king moves no matter where
it goes there's an attack opened up
against the black queen wow what a huge
huge blunder by napomniachi and uh
you're right david it's
all to do with failing to calculate the
checks the captures
and attacks it was sloppy sloppy yeah
with the knight so it is slightly
understandable and actually i would have
modified if i'd seen that check i would
have modified my suggestion of the rook
move
but okay um yeah yeah
he's blood he's lost the exchange
and unfortunately it won't be just the
exchange that he's losing because
a pawn drops when okay there we go rook
takes pawn so now it's
it's exactly a rook for a night pawns
are level right now
and um yeah the rooks they will combine
they will be able to target black's
pawns
black's knight doesn't have a real
strong hold um long term
okay the black king stepping forward
that's a good
practical try um activating the king
magnus now he's got options he can bring
the other rook across to support he can
just drop that rook back
and okay he's you asked whether there's
any hope ivanka it's probably
that's his last hope those two pawns on
the right side is two versus one on that
right flank
what do you think the chances are of
saving this game
uh well we we've seen magnus be uh
in-game virtuoso
so we've seen not seeing the like or i
think the chances are very very minimal
i mean it requires a huge
blunder from magnus and i just don't see
that's going to happen
and there you can see that magnus is
opening up
lines for his rook and now he's
yep so no i just both the players moved
and i wanted to have the game finished
at that precise minute but no
they're just uh stretching yeah i was
like what's happening
is there because there's still hope for
nepo here right
there's still hope um it's disappearing
by the movement
um there's yeah it's definitely not the
type of position you resign
um i i know and i mean i still would
never dream of resigning this even if i
were playing magnus carlsen
um because knights if especially in
rapid chess when the clocks is ticking
down
knights are so tricky you can imagine
them jumping around causing all sorts of
havoc
against the white king against the
against the white rocks also black does
have these two this two verses one
advantage
and he's trying to push um you should
always push pawns
on the side that you're stronger don't
push the pawns on the side where you're
weaker or where you have
uh your own king but um black's now
he is gonna bank everything on those two
black pawns on the right side there we
go
and he's doing just like you said david
he's pushing his pawn
and now the question is can magnus
simply get greedy and
trust that his rook is going to be
flexible enough to
defend from the back and i think as you
mentioned ivanka after rook takes pawn
right now white's rook
will find it the whole way around and it
will stop black's pawns on the right
side from behind that's the key thing
okay well magnus doesn't do that instead
he
centralizes his king this is uh
slove by magnus right the white king
stepping across they're
very accurate very accurate either yeah
i'm just thinking that he's calculated
well actually i'm not going to say
calculator i'm going to say intuited
that
his king is perhaps a good defender and
can
hold off those pawns on the right i
think magnus now
he is starting to calculate but now he's
realizing it's not as easy as maybe it
should have been
and okay we do see the rooks about to
leave the board
um only actually just taking a short
break there but now pawn takes rook
and what do you think javanka king rush
that white king over to the right side
yeah that's the most solid way of
dealing with those pawns for sure
maybe jumping into the center of the
board then jumping towards the right
jumping towards white's born in the
corner he's mobilizing the king
it's getting ready i mean i i predicted
the the king would step up
one square further but okay okay
on the board as a threat that's a big
threat in the position actually black is
threatened to push his other pawn now
shall we share it david we do have to
show that danger
um if magnus is very careless and
if she pushes the pawn he has to say
then uh napomniacci
will jump for joy and push his own pawn
because the point is that after pawn
takes pawn
well oh dear
and yeah fast start for my mama jaroff
and these two players they did start
well and okay wow
magnus carson bringing his king across
and napoleon actually just ignores the
fact
that well at least i thought that
there was a big trick there david he
couldn't have captured that pawn
because uh do we have time to show it
yeah let's bring up the analysis board
there was a trick of white capturing
this pawn and now black
jumping forward with his own pawn and
now if we stop it
if we stop this black pawn from
promoting after knight takes pawn check
the king moves and now black will make a
new queen and the black knight defends
it
but okay they have been moved so instead
of allowing this
white did bring his king across and now
after the rook
steps back i don't think this has gone
very well for magnus castle now the
black knight is jumping forward
check about pick off a pawn and i did
mention earlier vancouver white is
running out of pawns on this side
um one versus one on this one side and
white's king being so far away
i don't think it's going to be enough
for magnus carson to win any more he's
just running out of pawns
you did say it and i refuse to believe
it
still i mean you can still argue that
white has winning chances here
no i i did not see it david i was like
there is no way on earth that's going to
happen
and uh once those pawns get traded off
it's just a draw
rook versus knight um it's not
completely basic there are some tricks
but
for these players it's quite elementary
i think a rook will never beat a knight
on its own the black knight will be able
to defend
um its own king so okay we do see a
couple of pawn pushers there i was about
to say before those pawns pushed
i was about to ask you whether it
reminded you of any end game ivanka
especially if the white king was able to
suddenly magically transport itself over
to the left side
it would have actually been a kind of
mirror image of the game
caruana versus vashi legrav from the
candidates the same pawns the same
rook versus night combo but now we see
white's king is just too far away from
the action black's knight is about to
attack white's pawn
and that white pawn um yeah i don't
think there's any way to
preserve it essentially no napoleon just
he's got plenty of time six minutes he's
just going to find a way to trade off
his own pawn for white's porn and that's
it should be a draw great save by him
then i mean
a few minutes ago you we asked you uh
can napomiaccia save it ah you weren't
too sure about it
you were thinking resignation wasn't
that question and
um totally i mean this is the kind of
beauty of chess in her yeah it was
it was a very careless mistake by
napolita
but you know he fought so hard so well
to kind of get this position
and uh it does look like a draw is
very much within reach but uh yeah what
a save
yeah what a save and maybe it's just
missed opportunities as well for magnus
it didn't look like he
found the most direct way to win he did
hesitate maybe he
it was too slow this plan bringing his
king over
and um yeah unfortunately i'm proving
for napoliyachi
just like it is for bitcoin slightly
over the last couple of minutes
wow the first meet between these two
after uh realizing they will face each
other in the world chess championship
match
magnus carlsen in what he is normally an
expert
in the end game right yeah sort of
missing out on the winning chances
yeah it feels like his calculation
wasn't quite uh what it usually is
over the last few moves and okay there
we go napoli actually
bring his knight to attack white's rook
that rook will move and then black will
just bring his pawn down
one square to try and trade pawns yeah i
think if magnus
nelson is to win uh the world
championship match against the pontiac
he's going to have to grind out these
games a bit better yeah he's going to be
have to be super accurate napoli
actually
once you give him a chance um he will
take it and there we go the pawns
disappear from the board and the play
is just agree a draw king versus king no
chance magnus not even trying to win
that one
miraculous save by no pomiacci wow i
can't believe it we just saw the first
game
between these two after nephew won the
can